yeah I've always said about Zelda I love
a fantasy plot heavy game yeah yeah it's
a good time yeah how's that game going
by the way it's going so well do they
still have levels and no it's just open
world you go you just I mean they like
lead you to the town of path so you
don't go you know just willy-nilly and
get lost but everything's kind of open
it really gives you a sense of adventure
because sometimes you just find caves
and then it says Discovery and then yeah
it plays a little note of music and
you're like oh man the flute yeah I
remember the food and then I remember
the fishing pond from N64 catch a lunker
[Laughter]
yeah probably actually no way more than